so two weeks ago I did a video on how to
choose a mentor that did incredibly well
I got a lot of comments from and many
who came back and said Pat it's great to
know how to choose a mentor and find the
trifecta but how do I find a mentor and
keep the mentor in my life and that's
what we're doing today so I decided
bring a couple of my friends
George polio as well as Jose gaitán who
have had the privilege a mentor and
nearly a decade both of them and now
they mentors others as well across the
country they've done incredible jobs for
themselves both of them our trifecta
type of leaders that they don't just
tell you what to do they're experiencing
in themselves so we came early this
morning was kind of a cool experience
this morning I brought my boy Edwin
Lopez from artistic Auto Detailing who I
believe is the most incredible auto
detailer in the country the only guy
that services five Bugattis and I think
it's seven Bugattis now Edwin your
service in he does - uh Pagani's there's
only foreign American services two of
them you talk about Ferraris Lambo is
the way they do it how articulate there
how specific they are I've just never
met anybody that so good at what he does
and at the end he'll I'll have them say
a couple words about his company what
they're doing good friend of mine so
let's get right into it let's get right
into it we have the nice cars behind us
I mean it's kind of cool when you got a
650 horsepower 0-60 2016 when you got a
brand spanking new Tesla here whoo when
you turn it on you don't hear anything
from it and you got a Ferrari for 518 I
don't know if we're in the mood maybe
maybe later on we race what do you think
about that let's see are you okay if we
raced a little bit let's do it 50 cops
in LA will let us do it because we also
have a lot of police officers that watch
these videos today all of you took the
day off for that 30 minutes that we go
off the race if we do so so George
you went from I met you at 18 you went
from an 18 year old to now a self-made
guy you run your multi million out of
your business you do well for yourself
but you were 18 when you first decided
become an entrepreneur how did you go
what could you say to everybody out
there and how you went from finding a
mentor and keeping a mentor I think that
in order to find a mentor keep a mentor
you first need to
be ready for one you know whatever
you're doing whatever you're out right
now some people feel well I'm not the
job that I want to be at so I'm just not
gonna give it my best effort and I think
that that's not a way of going through
life whatever you're doing maybe it's
not where you want to end up but if you
give everything that you have to
whatever you're doing you do the best
that you can that becomes a habit and so
when you do end up finding a mentor
that's a habit already instilled in you
but point number one to finding a mentor
for me was to find somebody that had the
life that I wanted hmm you know so
getting a chance to get involved in the
industry and meet you know meet yourself
and see the lifestyle and see the income
and see the the leadership if you find
somebody that's already exemplifying the
qualities as a person that of a person
that you want to be or already has a
lifestyle that you want to have or is
making the income you want to make and
it's a model you know like ours where
you're able to get mentorship from that
person that's that's my point number one
is look for somebody that has the life
that you want that's a very good point
Jose what would you say mentorships
everything you know when you think about
doing something good and or great as a
book says from good to great if you
wonder something great you got to go up
and find a mentor I was looking up to
Richard Branson who he's got and he said
the future of any successful person that
wants to become great is to find a
mentor it's standing on the shoulders of
giants I think if you really want to do
something big in your life you really
want to get what and find a mentor like
Georgia said that's already been
established that's what you want to do
something great in your life most people
don't they just want to do something
good in her life one do something great
you got to go out there stand on the
shoulders of giants I've been there and
I think to attract the mentor to find a
mentor you got to be attractive and in
many ways in many ways you got to be
attractive sometimes you want to go
through and see come because they're
already established but they're looking
at you more than you're looking at them
so if you're attractive in a way where
you have desire you want to do something
big in your life it's not just a regular
lifestyle you want a button burr foo
pursue you got to become attractive and
find yourself that mentor now let me ask
you a question so either one of you guys
can take this one you know sometimes I
can think for my own mentors the
relationship with the mentors that some
people have a hard time with a mentor as
you're going through it what are some
difficulties about having a strong
mentor they could share with everybody
I think first of all ego if you think
about the the lineage Plato mentored
Aristotle Aristotle mentor Alexander the
Great the Zuckerberg with mentors was
Steve Jobs so this goes on and I think
all those guys had egos at one point so
the biggest deal the the biggest foam I
tend to find is that you can't set aside
your ego you got to be coachable and
teachable if someone's already been
there and done that you mean you've got
to set aside you've got to say that's
the biggest challenge that I find for
for someone to receive it
as a set aside their ego what would you
say George I think most of us never are
around people that have high
expectations and for majority the people
around us in our lives don't have high
expectations so when you finally find a
mentor you got to know that that person
has extremely high expectations and so
often times there's a level of
frustration in working with them because
they expect so much more than you and
nobody likes to be accountable for their
actions so maybe you know you shy away
and you don't want to be held
accountable because accountability
points out your flaws you know so in
that you get challenged you take it
personal and you feel they're
challenging you personally instead of
maybe challenging what you're doing and
so to be able to separate the challenge
as a that they're challenging you in
business or they're challenging your
performance versus challenging you as a
human I think ego plays a big part into
that so let me ask you that's a good
point so I get asked people will say hey
Pat you know can you send me can you
help me with a couple thousand dollars
for me to start my own business can you
do this can you do that they constantly
feel like hey I'm in a very bad
predicament you don't know how my
financial situation you don't assign
what I'm going through you don't assign
how difficult it is for me it's so hard
I want to quit why don't you tell a real
story of a point where maybe you
yourself were absolutely done he said
I'm not doing this no more I'm just sick
of being an entrepreneur I'm gonna go
and take a different life was there
every time we had a breaking point we
wanted to give up sure when I got
started in business I think my first six
months we made like $8,000 my next
twelve months we made like 16,000 and
then finally like the third year making
32,000 which is less than I was making
at my job so sometimes you take a step
back to take take a step forward and I
was just really really really really
frustrated
my mom got cancer
she was in the hospital she was getting
breast cancer surgery and my business
wasn't working out my bills were late
all my bank accounts were we're very low
or negative my credit cards were we're
not being paid I was just sittin old
were you at this point I was 21 1 20 21
years old and I'm in the hospital and
I'm just breaking down saying my
business isn't working my family life is
falling apart
God what's going on just at a very low
state and that's where mentor also
really comes in I remember giving you a
call and having a conversation and you
just need somebody that believes in you
and knows your gifts and giving you hope
and encouragement but that was at a
really really lonely place and without a
mentor at that point I think I would
have went the other route I probably
would've went back to a job and just
gone back to what was comfortable but
that mentors are one that sees your
future you and challenges you to become
that person while sympathizing with your
situation so how do you at that point
because I mean I've mentored thousands
of people that many don't want to take
that mentorship and the challenge how do
what do you do to be willing to take it
right I mean because you've got to be
willing to take the coaching and the
challenge what is the mindset and being
willing to take somebody pushing you and
challenging you I think we're great to
what georges mentioned is that something
I can totally relate to starting my own
starting in the business and and having
breakthroughs and sometimes you want to
judge where you're at right now it
doesn't know or really care it's about
where you're going and the character the
entrepreneur is really built through
that tough time but how do you take it
you got to really decide do you want to
be where you're at I can't have a real
real honest conversation where you're at
if the answer is no then what are you
gonna do about it so you got to be very
real with yourself rolling ruin and and
no more BS and just realize that find
someone has done it you have that they
have the life that you want go out there
and mimic it by being coachable and
teachable so you got to be my opinion
bear real with yourself did you have a
breaking point yourself where you
absolutely didn't believe where you
wanted to give up what was your breaking
like is there a star remember one myself
with you with the whole car outside on
you and I are talking 12 1 o'clock but
what what comes to mind when you think
about it you know when we talk about you
got to have faith when it
really counts me sometimes when you're
having a breakdown you you don't
practice your faith you gotta have faith
through adversity so I have countless
stories where I didn't have any gas
money we had to go out there and sell a
bunch of things online just to go out
there and make ends meet sometimes when
you don't think you need to be doing
these things you have to be doing these
things and sometimes you don't think you
need to feed your business or pay your
business and your business keeps you in
business so it's not about anything else
you're behind on rent car show it's all
that stuff so we had those moments where
it was dark we didn't know we can get
through but that's when our faith really
came through and that's where a mentor
was there to guide you along the way did
you struggle with either one of you guys
can take this one did you struggle with
say for instance a father a mother a
brother or sister a friend somebody
saying George what are you doing why are
you putting yourself through this so a
lot of because you coming from a person
you love it's coming from a family
somebody you've known all your life how
do you how do you how do you manage that
yourself when it comes down to close
family you've known all your life saying
George I think you need to just go out
and get a job you're really struggling
you're having a hard time with fine what
would you say about that I want to I
want to comment on the question you
asked a second ago about how do you
handle the adversity I think that if you
overcome one of those breakthrough
breakdowns when you're having a
breakdown if you overcome it you find
out and you get to know that there's a
stronger you inside of you and I think
that you have to finally overcome one of
those challenges to know like I can do
this I am better there's a saying that
in your breakdown you have a
breakthrough and it's kind of like the
onion peeling away the layers of the
onion you have all these excuses you
makin most of time maybe you're in a
tough financial situation because of
what you're not doing
you know and that forces you that pain
that pain forces you to change to
finally perform and then you get the
results and so that's what what happened
for me and once you overcome at one time
then the next time that challenge comes
you know you can do this going back to
that question when I got star in the
business and my dad will probably watch
this here all right we just bought this
this car the other day was his dream car
so drove it up to the house he came out
loved it but when I Drive it he drove it
that was it was he was really pushing it
yeah he loved it zero to sixty like this
and
it's his dream car was my dream car and
so when I guess around the business
though he would always say what are you
doing where's your income why aren't you
making money why isn't this working why
you getting home at 12 1 o'clock 2
o'clock at night what are you doing
right what are you doing at your office
what are you doing why you not you know
and oftentimes they care about you so
they're trying to give you good advice
but when you take somebody's advice when
you buy somebody's advice you buy their
lifestyle you know and at that time I
saw where my family was out financially
and I saw where you were at and other
people that were successful and there
was a process that they had to go
through so I had faith in the process
that there would be a payoff at the end
instead of listening to those people
that were questioning me at that moment
now what have you been able to do for
your family over the years why don't you
once you talk about some of the
victories as an entrepreneur you've been
able to provide for your mom dad family
that you have sure with the whole real
estate thing you know we we lost our
ended up losing our home and and so at
that time we were able to come in and
buy a property my parents always wanted
to breed German shepherds and get a
ranch so we bought a three and a half
acre property and built a kennel on it
and now that business you know through
their breeding producers I'm a
six-figure income every year in
retirement you know and eating lamb
producing a six-figure income in
retirement absolutely because of
property yeah how amazing is that
yeah unbelievable and so mom doesn't mom
doesn't work you know they work at the
ranch and you know and that's what they
do together now they have you know
they're their business and it's changed
her life you know it's no more her
having to listen to a boss it's no more
her you know having to go work every day
and get disrespected I didn't want my
family to go through that and so we
bought him a ranch we travel we travel
all over the world together and it's
changed our life so now they're grateful
that we didn't listen to that advice
when it was being given and you know
Gladys if you're watching this we were
just saying earlier how amazing of a
mother you are and George always says
you're an angel but I remember also
going with your father too we went to we
went to the Derby one time I went to
Derby with your pops so George if you're
watching this you got to be one of the
coolest cats to travel with he is he is
absolutely entertaining and fun to be
around but but what could you say what's
happened with you and your family what's
happened with you and some of the dreams
because you stopped when I first met you
were single you were driving a Sebring
right right and you
you you were bill collector I believe
it's what you were going what's what's
been the evolution with us and sticking
around not giving up finding a mentor
what's happening with you throughout the
process and going back to the question
about what you had to go through there's
an old quote says being an entrepreneurs
doing something for a short period of
time that most people aren't willing to
do to live a lifestyle that most people
only dream of and eventually you gonna
have that lifestyle so we had to have
those breakthroughs that we discussed
and having no background in this
industry having no background and being
an entrepreneur over the last six years
of doing this or six to ten years the
evolution of my wife are not coming
together and my wife in the business we
have a beautiful son we have another son
all the way and to be able to give our
son experiences to go to Aspen to go to
Monaco next year to go to Dubai to go to
Italy place it all over the world be
able to take my mom to Italy to see the
expression on your mother's face for all
the hard work because all we all to our
family at this point is to give them
good memories and experiences so to be
able to give that back to my mom my
mother-in-law and we have countless
places around the world that we're gonna
go to it's all because you've sold out
to becoming an entrepreneur
now did you visualize this line like did
this happen by accident was there a
formula that worked for you did you do
something did you write it on a piece of
paper that you have a vision board or
was a pure luck how did this life all of
us some present itself to you sure I
remember when I get started in the
business my mentor said do a vision
board and so I did a vision board and on
that vision board was the kind of life
that I wanted places we want to travel
homes we wanted to buy the ranch the
kennel the Corvette and what's
interesting is everywhere on that vision
board everything that's on that vision
board we've accomplished everything on
the vision were you've accomplished yeah
from buying a ranch from from getting
the kennel from buying the vet from
traveling the world all the places we
wanted to go there we visited all of
them so far so it's been an amazing
experience if you're not you need to
kind of get a picture of the life you
want and affirmations really help with
that you know having a mindset that you
repeat every day to yourself that's
victorious it's powerful that's maybe
where you're gonna go I think that's
really important vision boards really
important mentorship is really important
do you have your vision board with you I
do was in the car yeah once you grab the
vision board yeah so say while he was
doing I want you and
how about yourself did this kind of
happened by pure accident or was this
was it was it something that you did
that also helped you have the life that
you have now now first you hear it and
you see and you think yeah right but you
know I realize that there are no secrets
they're just all in books and the
biggest thing is people don't read there
are no secrets they're all in books the
wrong books is that that's the biggest
challenge of most people they need any
books so after reading and then evolving
myself I remember last year we've had
many vision boards my wife and I it was
whether it was Italy going to Rome going
to Pisa we're going to Dubai in 2014 we
had a vision board 2014 of the tall's
Hotel in the world in Dubai we ended up
going this year and my earlier vision
board and excuse me win last year and my
earlier vision board 2015 had a Tesla
that I wanted I wanted to have a Tesla
and along with a bunch of other things
and we've been able to accomplish all
those things but it's there's no secret
read the books find a mentor and just
stick with it you got to stick with it
maybe we can talk about the books after
George shows us his vision board sure so
this was this was the ranch up here and
now we have a three and half acre
property this was just kind of jump down
here this was the the car which is so
funny so you can see the picture of the
car here right I want to say that was
maybe 2006 there's another one right
here on this one of the same car 2006
1223 2000 you kept all this stuff from
10 years ago absolutely I love it
absolutely I think can I see this yep
from 10 years ago the making of a
champion Paul can you see it oh you want
me to tell me if you want a zoom or not
move or pull it back a little bit so you
got making up a champion oh we've been
here before we wrote a we it's funny one
day we went to on this trip and I'm
kayaking and I look up at the rock
formation I remember that was a problem
believable yeah we character right
through there unbelievable
we've been on a private jet before why
we went to Pebble Beach before Puerto
Rico three sports cars right there three
sports cars right here that means sports
cars right here so these are things that
are important you know get an idea of
the life you want and dream big you know
when I when I put this on here I was 19
years old you know I couldn't afford
$100,000 car and do sticking through
your dreams and your goals show the date
for
on the date can you zoom in on the date
that's the key we're talking 12 years
ten years ago 11 years ago no nine years
ago is what we're talking about in
today's before Christmas so you had
asked me a question you said did you
ever think it was gonna come true right
and you started I think most of us we
hope to win but we expect to fail
because of past failures that we have so
maybe the confidence isn't there and
eventually you have to establish that
one day you got to stop running you know
I didn't do it in sports I didn't do it
in school and then when the business got
hard I was gonna repeat the same mistake
of quitting and quit quitting becomes a
habit but I kept running away instead of
finally becoming a better person and
sticking with the problem and Einstein
said it's not that I'm smarter than you
just as I say with problems longer than
you and I decided that this was gonna be
the last place I went that I ran away
from and to stick it out and so I didn't
think it was gonna happen and the other
thing too the second part to that stay
on that run away to hold that thought on
the second part so running away meaning
what we get to a point and in order not
to face of failure or in order to kind
of have used that as an alibi to run
away is that what you mean by running
away yeah absolutely it was so many
times every single day I think when I
when we start the business every day two
three times a day I would you think
about quitting and going back to a job
you know and then I would have to
process my own thoughts and I think
that's an important part you process
your own thoughts where I was like am i
doing that because that's my calling you
mind doing that because that's my
purpose where am I doing that because
that's easier right and I knew in my
mind it wasn't because I was meant to be
a server at Red Lobster the rest of my
life it was just easier and so was I
gonna buy my own excuse and the second
part that is I thought this was gonna
happen within a year you know I thought
by 2007 I'd be a millionaire and have a
Corvette and it took so much longer at
the same time than I thought it was
gonna be so sometimes you know you'll
set a goal and if you just want to stay
on course maybe it will take you twice
the amount of time but at least you'll
accomplish it if you don't give up we
overestimate but we can do in a short
amount of time
and we underestimate what we can do over
five or ten years at this point very
very good point it's so good both of you
guys let me ask you how big of a role
has books played in your life how big of
a role has reading books played in your
maybe think about a book that really
impacted your life what would you say
about reading and which book has
impacted you the most these are several
there's several I can't even thing you
started off with good too but you talk
with what you thought
I mean I mean
the separator is the books guys the
books that you read the the meetings you
attend the people you associate with is
a separator you want to become somebody
great again most people live a very good
life and they think it's good but
compared to compared to what good is the
enemy of great
and to become great you got to go read
about greatness and go get inspired by
them to go figure them out when I think
about books jeez there's so many um I
would say outwitting the devil is a book
I forgot who wrote that book I would in
the devil but it really Aaron Lecter
I think it's Sharon Lechter Napoleon
Hill right Napoleon Hill and and Sharon
Lechter so that I would in the devil
really it's that allows you to take a
look at the man or woman in the mirror
and that's typically the most disturbing
thing you can possibly do because you
avoid it the person you currently are
for the fear of the person that you
could possibly become and that typically
holds you back but there's countless
books and I wouldn't be where I'm at
today if it wasn't for reading period
about yourself one of my favorite books
because I struggle with a limiting
belief in securities was beyond positive
thinking by dr. Robert Anthony and in
the book he talks about the most people
there is have do B versus B do have and
it says when I have you know the great
lifestyle when I have the money when I
have the houses when I have the car when
I have the business then I'll do what
successful people do then I'll be
successful and the challenge with that
is that you're always waiting for
something that happened before you make
a decision versus B do have I'm gonna go
be that leader now I'm gonna go be a CEO
I'm gonna go act like I'm a million
dollar earner you know I'm gonna go take
action like that and once you once you
ensure that then you'll do those things
that produce the results so instead of
waiting to have it go be it and that
will catch up with you let me ask you
sometimes sometimes we we only see the
final product right we see the final
product and you know look good nice
lifestyle nice cars nice place nice
parties nice places you travel to you
know places you go to where you stay at
Dubai at a place that it's a twenty
thousand dollar trip where you go
there's just Dubai and so somebody else
sees it and they say man I'm so far from
believing that I can have that life is
there a story
either one of you guys can take the lead
on this now you want to share that
somebody can hear this and say man that
resonates with me is there something you
can think about that could resonate with
somebody I'm not just talking about a
breaking point I'm talking about either
a point where you had that you had your
own major breakthrough where you went
from a level where you're making decent
money let's just say you were starting
to make money you're doing okay now
but how did you go from that level to
all of a sudden having a breakthrough do
you have a story of a breakthrough that
was a very painful difficult point of
your life that you had to go through it
is their story like they can think about
you know there are several and I think
about anyone I want I want to hear a
specific story I'm thinking about I
remember doing something new coming from
collections background sure no degree
wasn't sure where I wanted to go but I
know wanted to do something big in my
life and I remember being in my car
after not not passing an exam on how to
pass six months later
twice in my car now I'm in tears I'm
thinking what am I gonna do if I don't
if I don't pass this if I don't if I
don't have a breakthrough this is
entirely different industry but I knew I
wanted to do something in this for me it
was in a car with tears thinking is am I
gonna go back to that regular life and
the breakthrough was when I didn't quit
so very easily could have gone back
because it was easy but I didn't quit at
that moment and and that would that was
one one that I remember had a
breakthrough and led to everything else
my mother saw it I think mine was when
we decided to start our own company and
just was at a place where went without
income for months and still had to pay
bills and my bank account in December
December 2006
I'm sorry December 2009 my bank accounts
negative $600 this is what month
December 2009 this is three months after
starting the company December 2009 my
bank accounts negative $600 I haven't
paid any of the credit cards cuz I just
have no more money and I get a call from
my mom and she says hey there's some guy
outside the house and what's going on
and he keeps coming back and knock and I
said well pin the door and see what do
you want
and he's like you just got served you
know so in the middle of starting a
company getting a lawsuit you know
getting sued by that company trying to
just put us out of business and I'd be
running appointments you know on faith
and just struggling financially one in
appointments running appointment
appointment hoping that just things just
happen and then at the end of the night
me 10 11 o'clock at night and we'd
finished out the other lawyer's office
and then in front of everybody put on
this face that things are good and we're
gonna go do something great because you
know you don't share those painful
moments those are the the moments that
you're by yourself you know that you're
there lonely you break down maybe you
journal I think journaling really helps
you process your own thoughts but it was
just it was a it was a breaking moment
and then two months after that not even
having the money and saying you know
what I'm gonna go open my own office in
the middle of this struggling
financially whatever got a couple
thousand dollars together when it opened
my first office with two thousand
dollars and you're not talking about an
office like an executive suite you open
you'll find it through your lease
three-year lease it's not $100,000
$150,000 lease you sign okay yep and in
to start an office with $2,000 you know
buying furniture from from from garage
sales building we our podium we built
them we built our podiums and one of our
associates in dqo BOCES her dad built
the podiums for the office with no money
you know and then six months later going
and starting another office with no
money and then all of a sudden that
month $30,000 deposits and now that's a
normal thing but the question is would
you you know what would you do when
you're negative what would you do when
you're getting sued what would you do
when you're not making money would you
take on more responsibility would you
push more would you challenge yourself
more most of us we retreat and we go
back to us and that's where we stay who
we are and I think that's your breaking
point that's your that's where you get
your breakthrough so you have to fight
that battle and that's where you build
that pride in that confidence that you
can do anything else very very good
point I mean we can talk to these guys
and they're be Nuggets all the time
maybe maybe we'll have them come back
again on a couple other episodes in the
future so Jose how can people find you
Jose Gaitan the name's gonna show on the
screen
Jose guys town they can find you on
Facebook social media Instagram they so
look for Jose Jose guy John George how
can I find you yeah through Facebook
Instagram you can go to George Clio com
it's my website and George plan you can
actually put George plan on YouTube as
well you got a few videos on YouTube
subscribe to this channel you're gonna
see a lot more from both of these guys
here
but look it's kind of the end of the
video and I don't know if you're in the
mood or not or you guys kind of the mood
to race you want to keep this video just
to know it okay if we put some week we
brought value I don't I don't know if we
have an agenda yet you got your gear on
just sent me I'm a sinner guy so I keep
sporting sin any Senate suppose I've
gotta let me keep sending it to me I get
a lot of good stuff that gets sent over
but I said we go right let's go right
okay with you guys it's correct I come
in a minute so listen who do you bet on
you bet on the Ferrari Tesla or there's
no six you make your vote but let's see
who wins
when it comes down to most people who do
detail car wash your car they normally
use the bucket system which is only a
buck if I've got two 5-gallon buckets
when a soap one has water and normally
has a sponge we don't do that we've
actually created something where we
eliminate trying to damage as least as
possible the vehicle so what we do is we
dope we never double use rice every
single car that we wash has its own
micro fabric system so that means
normally when we do it we service a
vehicle each each car will get its own
microfiber eggs well normally each car
and the service you will be using about
45 rags what we've done is we've created
our own filtration system to be able to
do to have di water which is deionized
water and the reason we've done this
because we want it to have no
interruptions whenever we're detailing
our customers cars whether we're in
Beverly Hills were in the desert
wherever it might be and this is
something that almost nobody has in
their detailing system so what we wanted
to do is we want to be different wanted
to be able to be anywhere and be able to
filtered regular hard water into di
water filtration water to be able to
have spot free water so what we've done
is we've hooked up this reel where we
can connect anywhere in anybody's home
the water runs through here through this
system through our filtration system
cleans out the water we have a 60 gallon
tank here where it restores our water
and it pretty much everything is hooked
up we're we're ready to just go ahead
and continue to detail cars without any
hesitation or or stopping the type of
vehicles that we've service some of the
most in need are anything from Bugattis
Pagani's the pencils Lamborghinis
Ferraris you name it majority of all the
cars that are out in this and this
industry we've done well we reach
service vehicles everywhere are
obviously our home base is in Beverly
Hills but we've done vehicles in about
16 states we've traveled cross-country
we have negotiations right now to
probably go to Dubai and being able to
do something over there so we've
expanded to just anywhere where the
client wants to go what makes us
different from everybody else is there
not only do we give great quality
service but we also bring classiness to
us and what I mean by that is the way we
present ourselves from our ties our
dress shirts how we speak are the way we
our presentation of our vans the
chemicals we use nothing is generic
everything we use is high definition
quality but one of the reasons I think
that entrepreneurs uses a lot and we're
leading into this industry is because of
the time Savior that we use and what we
what I mean by that is that we save them
that time of having to have to go to the
carwash
having to bring in having to have to
spend an hour that time they could use
either spending with their kids or
family being on meetings being on hotels
or whatever it might be
so by the time they come out their
vehicles are ready in our cert the way
we service our clients it's a 24 hour
service or anytime they call us whether
it's day 9 morning anywhere in the u.s.
that they're at we could most likely
take care of them I think one of the
reasons the united heat setters
coalition was created was because there
is a 98% of the Detailers out there that
what I've seen or I've met who are
struggling in their business and I think
one of the reason was because they were
fighting for a clientele and they were
marketing their business right that
we're doing that were concentrating more
on trying to compete on prices more than
giving the customer something unique
like the quality of work the
presentation um you know it's stuff like
that that made us stand out from
everybody else so what I did with our
with artistic was I wanted to brand
myself away from everybody else I wanted
to bring in classy service along with
great skills through the customer front
door
the reason Detailers are partnering up
with the United Detailers Coalition is
because even though they've been in
business for 10 15 years they wanted the
guidance and the mentorship from other
Detailers not only myself but also other
Detailers and that are needing
this industry that have never met each
other and what I mean by that is you
know we're sharing each other's tips and
secrets to be able to help each other
because there's about 75,000 Detailers
out in the United States more Earth
estimated that are you know in need of
help to be able to grow their business
and I think we can all agree I think
last year to Cystic show that there were
70 1.3 million new cars sold in the US
so there's enough cars for everybody if
anybody wants more information about the
UDC movement you could go to UDC
movement comm or they're interested in
our service that you do go to artistic
auto detailing comm